tell us do we really need a surveillance
program like this well you need one you
just don't need one quite this bigger
this energetic that that's the problem I
think that's the reason why Edward
Snowden decided to blow the whistle on
it when you say banner jeddak what do
you mean well going after turning the
NSA basically on to the American public
you know there's not a person in the
country that doesn't have some of its
information with regard to telephone
calls inside NSA at this point that
wasn't the purpose the agency was set
for and it's by far something that
shouldn't be done well I want to talk to
you about the evolution of the NSA
here's a quote from your book from a
number of years ago a more innocent time
in place this of course after September
11th the war was in an upward death
spiral the president's national ratings
were below sea level and Congress was in
the hands of angry Democrats it was a
bad time - at last seek legislation
there's been an evolution of the NSA
through time where do you think they
will be in one or two years mr. Bamford
well it's a president rate they'll just
keep growing and growing and growing I
did a cover story for Wired magazine
last year on their new data center that
they're building in in Utah it's a
massive 1 million square foot its
facility to accommodate everything new
that they're pulling into the agency so
it's you know it's just growing and
growing and growing with all the money
that the post 9/11 windfall that it's
been getting attrition the the the
facility in Utah is bigger than Sarah
ices shoe closet well that must be
saying that was right first absolutely
you know here's the issue and I want to
bring Richard into this conversation as
well because you know Jim we're living
in a very different day and age I mean
50 years ago when this is the NSA was
first getting started and they were
collecting data we were in a different
kind of warfare Richard what's different
about today whereas you would argue a
program like this is more necessary
well the NSA I mean it goes back to 1949
in some cases earlier before anyone had
even thought of the internet and so the
big challenge they've had to focus on
for the sort of the last 25 years is how
to deal with this incredible growth in
Internet enabled communications of all
shaped form and variety from voice
enabled telephone to email text
messaging encrypted text messaging cloud
servers video games with their own
proprietary and they they their mission
is to be able to get into those when it
threatens the United States and we yet
we need to get into the dr. falkenroth I
thought one of the great distinctions
this weekend this was Henry Blodgett
SRIA Lee good work at Business Insider
moving this dialogue forward and one of
the distinctions is there's a court
order and there's a bad person and name
the country and we go after them we all
get that but then there's this idea of
collecting data of just mining data and
storing it away for a rainy day when you
may have to go into it and search it are
we doing that and is that part of what
James Bamford NSA should do it is
something that we're doing and it is the
major legal change in fact in the old
days you didn't regard it you regarded
it as collection as soon as you tapped
into the wire that was connecting to
people for a phone call now what happens
is that is the agency is enabled to
ingest massive amounts data and then is
reviewed a second time before it doesn't
accesses them who did that James Bamford
are we supposed to blame somebody for
that or ask them to take a victory lap
who allowed them to ingest massive
amounts of data just for the sake of it
well that's the evolution of the NSA
every time there is a incident of some
sort the first cry as we need more data
we need more access we need more
capabilities I've interviewed a great
number of people at NSA and they lot of
them have the same view that mr. Snowden
had I interviewed for my Wired piece I
interviewed bill Binney he was one of
the most senior officials at NSA he was
a the person who basically created the
algorithm that uses all this data
collects all this data and he left the
agency because of after almost 40 years
because of all this excess
of eavesdropping on on Americans in the
United States targeting their
communications and so forth so I suppose
part of the much other people that that
have looked age are yeah I suppose part
of the question James is you know if
they're in fact he's dropping on all
these innocent Americans as you put it
are they actually doing any good here at
all in other words have they been able
to prevent another 9/11 in part because
of this this cyber technology has it
done any good not that I can see I've
written three books on the NSA numerous
articles and a documentary for PBS
interviewed numerous people I haven't
seen any of any useful outcome from all
this surveillance no you allow cuz I'll
stop there really get Richard fellows
jump in here and talk about the utility
of this to intelligence agents I think
one of the great distinctions trish over
the weekend as a beginning of the
intelligence people saying wait a minute
this helps each and every American is
that true I think it does I'll tell you
eight years on the inside in both the
White House and the NYPD there's nope no
instrument no tool in the toolbox more
powerful than electronic surveillance
for the government and trying to protect
our interest from terrorist attacks a
senator Obama had a stance he had a
position and I thought over the weekend
it was amazing how they showed his
migration to being president and if
somebody said arey Fleischer said out on
Twitter i retweeted it something the
effect it's a fourth Bush term in
intelligence because President Obama has
done much like President Bush did is
that true and it's true and Ari is being
a little provocative there but in fact
the President Obama the candidate and
the senator was against these sort of
things and what happens is once you
become president or you enter the
national security community you're privy
to the actual details interworking of
the program you see the value and here
you see a man who really is a liberal
constitutional law professor who comes
around now and is doing things which the
civil libertarians and the privacy
groups you know are as out rights as
they were with Bush he people are in
fact outraged they don't like the idea
of this in any way shape or form it's
very Big Brother feeling how do you
start to change public opinion is
as you say this is one of the key tools
in sorting turret I'm not sure they're
gonna be able to change public opinion I
mean step one was keep it a secret and
you know this was going on for years and
try not to tell anyone because there are
multiple reasons now that is no longer
secret what do you do I don't think
they're I think they're going to
struggle and there will likely be some
retrenchment the results from this
certainly abroad where these activities
may are illegal in some states whereas
here there seemed to be lawful James
Bamford last word to you if you had to
write an epilogue to your book today
what would you write well this would be
the chapter I'd write what happened here
are the whistleblowers has been more
whistleblowers national security
whistleblowers in the last seven years
than in the previous 50 years probably
so I think there's a large group inside
obviously there's a number of people on
the outside they keep pushing for more
and more and they think that they're
helping the country which they really
aren't but the people inside are saying
this is going too far and they're
risking their lives basically to try to
expose the secrets to the American
public